ladies and gentlemen your host for the
66th annual Academy Awards when we
Goldberg
good evening good evening thank you
welcome to ox cos 66 so they went and
gave me a live microphone for three
hours
there haven't been this many showbiz
executives so nervous sweating over one
woman since Heidi Fleiss honey
yeah hell sure unsure Billy Crystal
Thank You Billy Crystal used to have a
terrific way to open the show you know
you come out and do a bunch of cute
funny songs about the nominated movies
he got The Crying Game
I got Schindler's List Billy knew when
to leave so welcome to Hollywood's
biggest night
this year we discover if Oscars last
name really is Schindler there are a few
different things this year the Academy
had to tighten its belt you know so
instead of having an army of security
guards they hired Jack Nicholson and
James Caan
I mean come on Jack Nicholson and Jimmy
kind of strange behavior from two guys
who don't even have a rap album to
promote yeah like I said things are a
little different the host is wearing a
dress yes
and that is a first so let me spare you
the drama about the dress darling but
thank God for Ray Agee on you know what
I'm saying I was walking around the
house in this dress for six weeks
because I know at least a half a million
people are watching just to see what
everybody's got online and yes please
take note that Debbie Allen is wearing
the same color and same fabric as I am
but she has a blessed prayed and what a
breastplate stand up missing we are you
stand up so they know Debbie you know so
those slings and hours that you got they
popped right off
but you'll note that I went for the
Train normally I don't do trains but
honey it's the Oscars
and I want to put a rumor to rest I did
not get this gig because I'm Sydney poor
Jays daughter yeah it's been a lot of
speculation I got it because I seem to
cross so many ethnic and political lines
I'm an equal opportunity offender and to
make sure that you don't feel
shortchanged in the political soapbox
Department I'm going to get it all out
of my system right now save the whales
save the spotted owl gay rights men's
rights women's rights Human Rights feed
the homeless more gun control free the
Chinese dissidents peace in Bosnia
health care reform choose choice act up
more AIDS research left Frank Sinatra
finish look
lorena bobbitt please meet Bob Dole
and somebody stop these damn earthquakes
thank you
whoo I think I took care of everything
dinner including my career anyway
tonight we gather to honor Hollywood's
best which is also the world's best
people came from all of the world to
make movies and those movies are seen
all over the world we live in a global
multiplex the movies this year cover
depression abuse revolution people being
wrongly accused people being tortured
people fleeing for their lives and that
was just what's love got to do with it
you know
and there was so many terrific movies
this year you know pictures with a
strong social message like six degrees
of separation which turned out to be the
drawing instructions for Jessica rabbits
legs
that's why they hired me honey and we
can't forget to Rasik park the story of
what happens when you build an amusement
park and everything goes wrong the
original title was Euro Disney
and that's one real-estate Fiasco they
cannot blame on Hillary you know as
usual there were not enough good roles
for women this year but this time we can
blame it on Holly Hunter and Emma
Thompson no it's true because they found
all the good roles and played all of
them but that's cool
cuz neither one of them was in one of
the biggest hits of the year the
fugitive a thriller about a person who
spent days and days yes and days and
days running just one step ahead of the
law
but enough about Tonya Harding
now I know you nominees are sitting out
there and you're you're nervous and
you're sweaty I've been there baby relax
this is Magic night this is Oscar night
and the world is watching so I know I'm
gonna hurry up because I know people at
parties and bars and stuff and they put
the money into that pool and they're
clutching those bats then move along
whoop so that's exactly what I'm going
to do okay let's get to it